this is just asking questions a show for
inquiring minds on
reason today we're joined by Congressman
Thomas Massie house representative for
ky's fourth congressional district he's
a consistent opponent of government
deficit spending foreign aid and
overreaching federal mandates all of
which have occasionally left him as the
sole no vote on bills with otherwise
overwhelming support in DC which we'll
talk about today thank you for speaking
with reason Congressman Massie hey
thanks for having me on
Zack when you first uh the first thing I
want to ask you about is uh before we
get to your your kind of so descent uh
that that you've uh been the the soul
denter that you've been many times
before I want to talk about uh something
that's really pressing that's unfolding
in DC right now which is the re author
or a vote on the fisa reform and
reauthorization act and as part of that
the reauthorization of something called
section
702 um which uh essentially allows the
government to surveil Communications
between American citizens and foreign
targets without a warrant um and it
seems like now after some
resistance a clean preauthorization of
that is unlikely to happen it they're
attaching it to the National Defense
authorization act which is kind of like
the the the mil the defense budget for
the year um and they're they're trying
to slip a more temporary extension into
that could you just tell us what is at
stake for Americans with this issue
right so we're not trying to eliminate
the fisa 702 program it was established
to allow our intelligence agencies to
spy on foreigners without a warrant in
order to qualify to be spied on without
a warrant you have to be outside of the
country and you have to be not an
American citizen if you're inside the
country or if you're an American citizen
outside of the country you can't be
spied on by this program okay sounds
great right but we've got 250,000 people
on that list that were collecting
information on and in the process of
collecting that information it if you
talk to a business person in France for
instance you your emails and stuff may
get caught up in this data collection
well what they've been doing is they go
into this giant ball of you know data
and they put in your name they can put
in Zach's name and search it without a
warrant U without Reasonable Suspicion
or probable cause there's or and or any
of those sort of uh thresholds legal
thresholds not to investigate suspects
but to create suspects let's say that
you and Liz are at a protest and um they
developed some Nexus they say well we
think these protesters were inspired by
Russia okay um well we're just going to
run all the protesters names through
this database now even though the Intel
Community doesn't concede that they need
a warrant for this they've admitted that
they violated their own protocols
hundreds of thousands of times when they
search for us persons U data in this
hstack they say well it was created
legally so we don't need a warrant to go
search
it there are two proposals to
reauthorize this program by the way
there the only chance you ever get to
reform these programs is when they
expire so it's important that they do
expire occasionally and this one expires
in
January and in the Judiciary committee
which Jim Jordan chairs and on which I
serve we've marked up a bill that would
require them to get a warrant it would
create uh criminal penalties for people
in the executive branch who abuse the
program because there's never any uh you
know culpability or or blowback for
anybody that's abused this program um
but this would create that so we've
created this Reform Bill and then the
Intel committee has Crea a bill which is
less than ideal it doesn't have a
warrant requirement it doesn't have many
of the reporting requirements back to
Congress that the Judiciary bill has and
in fact it expands their ability to
collect information to for instance uh
if you had free Wi-Fi at a cafe that
that service provider would be treated
like Google or Verizon now and they
would have to create a direct pipeline
to the Intel agencies for any of the
communications that go through that so
that you got two proposals out there and
we're running out of time so what
speaker Johnson has proposed and some
Senators have proposed oh let's just
keep the old program in place for a
little bit longer your basic
Congressional kicking the can down the
road exercise that's going to be uh
passing the Senate probably today unless
Mike Lee and ran Paul can stop it then
it comes to the house probably tomorrow
now an interesting thing here is I serve
on the rules committee and Chip Roy and
Ralph Norman do as well and we told the
powers the be uh we're not going to we
can't go along with this so they
couldn't um pass a rule to combine the
fisa program with the ndaa that's how
they're going to try and get it through
attach it to must-pass legislation the
National Defense authorization act well
we said nope this shall not pass the
rules committee so they're going to try
and do this on suspension which and
there's a house rule that says if you
want to suspend all of our regular rules
and expedite something you need a
two-thirds vote of the house so this is
going to be interesting to see if they
can get effectively
290 uh people to vote for it yeah yeah
it is interesting because if you think
back to when a lot of Americans were
first awaken to this with the Snowden
Revelations about a decade ago uh there
were some sort of you know lonely
denters to just rubber stamping this
stuff yourself among them some of the
other people you mentioned Rand Paul
Mike Lee uh some people on the
Democratic side of the aisle uh it does
seem as if now there's more resistance I
mean I assume some of that has to do
with the way fisa was used uh against
the Trump Administration do you feel
like there's the political Tides have
shifted uh somewhat to the advantage of
people who care about privacy and
government surveillance yeah the tides
haven't just shifted the stars have
aligned okay we've we've never had a
chairman of either the Intel committee
or the Judiciary Committee who made
reforming this program one of their
priorities um and so with Jim Jordan
we're very lucky to have him as the
chairman of this committee and this is
one of his
signature uh agendas is to get this
reformed because we have seen abuses
that have been used against the
president um president Trump so cons a
lot of conservatives have woken up to
the fact that this program is being used
against them um you have liberals who
are upset about the program obviously
the FBI is using this against black
lives matter as well um and we we know
that to be the case so you do have this
Coalition of the left and the right
um it used to be a coalition of maybe a
dozen people right like it was me and
Justin OS and zo Lofgren and and tulsey
gabard maybe uh who were concerned about
this and we used to come together and we
would offer amendments to try to fix
this in the funding bills we would try
to defund some of this stuff which is a
really blunt instrument it's a lot
easier to write a legislation that
affects the laws than it is to just
defund something and they they would Pat
us on the head and say well you know we
appreciate the sentiment but this isn't
the time or place to to do what you're
doing and um you shouldn't be mucking
around with the funding but now is the
time in place the program is expiring
we've got uh a chairman who's
sympathetic to the cause and um a lot of
people a lot more people on the left and
the right who are you know this reported
out of the Judiciary Committee
35-2 there were only two denters and it
was on the Democrats side to the
Judiciary fisa Reform
Bill Congressman I want to ask about
foreign aid so this week seninsky came
to Washington and made his pitch for why
the United States uh in his eyes ought
to be funding Ukraine's uh war against
you know a horrible Invasion by Vladimir
Putin there's also obviously a you know
terrible foreign policy situation in the
Middle East right now between Israel and
Hamas you have called you know funding
Ukraine and F funding zalinski uh I
believe it was economically illiterate
and morally deficient yes make the case
for why you oppose this form of funding
well the economic illiteracy is in
reference to a letter that the White
House sent to the House of
Representatives last week and in two or
three of the paragraphs of the letter
they spouse the virtues of spending
money with the military-industrial
complex and sending that to Ukraine as a
job creation program that it would
reinvigorate our military industrial
complex they instead of I guess mic is
out of date it's now the dib the defense
industrial bases I guess they want their
dibs they're going to get their dibs on
our tax money but they they do they call
it the defense industrial base in the
letter and they made the economic
argument this is the broken window
fallacy for um Libertarians who are
watching this and so you got to be
economically illiterate You Got to
Believe In The Broken Window fallacy to
think this is will be economic stimulus
for the United States um meanwhile the
moral deficiency comes from some of the
Senators who have said that this war is
a great deal for America because all we
have to do is supply the weapons and
Ukraine supplies the soldiers and that
we're grinding down the uh the Russian
army and we're degrading their capacity
to do this this elsewhere or to commit
war against us the problem with that is
the numbers of people who are dying
zalinski allegedly told the Senators
that he's raising the uh draft age to 40
like this the ceiling on it and that you
know admitted that they are running out
of soldiers either through attrition on
the battlefield or from people who've
defected and and left the country and
you know you would think if this were a
war about the you know existence of
Ukraine and protecting a democracy and
such a fine government U that people
would sign up would volunteer to fight
for the country but the reality is
hundreds of thousands of them ones who
had the means uh and the money got out
of the country some are dying trying to
escape over mountains and Through Rivers
to get out of the country and far too
many have died on the battlefield we can
keep supplying them with weapons we can
keep depleting our treasure but they're
going to run out of fighting aged males
uh pretty soon but I want to push back
on that a little bit do you take that as
an indictment of Ukraine's democratic
system or more of a sense of you know
not that I want to advocate for military
conscription but a sense of leaving the
country because they see it as a warrant
which they will get creamed uh a war in
which it's you know just totally
unwinable like how do you look at that
situation and more broadly how should
Libertarians look at parallels or lack
thereof between the US's involvement in
funding Ukraine and the US funding
Israel well in your to your first
question I think it's both um they
they've lived in a country they know
that bribery and Corruption is part of
the culture and that the the current
government isn't even immune to that and
so um if you're fighting for your
country that's one thing but fighting
for the government that's in charge of
your country is another thing and so
that I believe that's part of it
obviously self-preservation is going to
be part of it as well you can't uh blame
anybody for that um so I think it's a
little bit of both um that makes in the
reason that they're leaving or not
wanting to fight um and then ultimately
look at look at where this is all going
to end up like when it's over there's
going to have to be some negotiated
peace settlement nobody I think believes
that Crimea is going to go back to
Ukraine and although that was one of the
stated objectives early on and probably
zalinski still stating that as sort of a
fairy tale and then the Eastern regions
that you know Russia had some control
over before the war are probably going
to be in control of Russ Russia after
this so why spend all the
lives um when the lines are going to be
where they were when it started I mean I
think it's just realism is a third
factor in that now what was your um
second question yeah let let me pick up
on Liz's second point there which is
about Israel uh because you've been kind
of on the lonely end certainly on the
Republican side of several votes
pertaining to Israel this is but one
example house resolution ution 771 which
is entitled standing with Israel as it
defends itself against the barbaric War
launched by Hamas and other terrorists
and what I'm displaying here is a tweet
from APAC which is the Israel Lobby
saying that you Thomas Massie are siding
with the squad with AOC and Rashida
Talib and ilon Omar and opposing
supporting Israel opposing condemning
Hamas uh you also were the sole vote
against kind of a symbolic uh
recognition of Israel and uh saying that
anti-Semitism uh or sorry anti-zionism
equates to anti-Semitism could you just
explain your stance on Israel where
you're coming from and what some of
these you think some of these critics
might be missing about your position
sure that was the first of 19 votes
today we're going to take our 19th
virtue signal vote here in Congress
um but I guess I got off on the wrong
foot early and have been voting
consistently ever since the title of
that bill is wonderful I have no
disagreement with the title of that bill
but there are four or five pages that go
after that title and um that well it's a
resolution the the first you know uh
objection I have to it was there was
inside of that an
open-ended uh pledge of military support
for Israel okay we've we never declare
Wars anymore the administration just
kind of goes and does it and Congress
keeps funding it but they find the EM
moer for their activity right there in
these resolutions so the open-ended
guarantee of um support for that war
that's contained in the text of that
bill but not the title could have
implied boots on the ground and that may
be the only vote we get to take in
Congress on on whether we're going to do
that or not so number one I don't
support that that notion um number two
there they were in that resolution they
mentioned
Iran okay in the very first resolution
they're already trying to expand the war
and incorporate as much of the Middle
East as they can there's some people
that just can't wait to attack Iran and
they want to use this as the Nexus to
get there so that was in the resolution
condemnation of Iran I think we should
be trying to constrain the conflict not
to expand it in the first resolution of
support that we pass there were also um
there was a a part of that uh resolution
wanted uh Stronger sanctions on Iran and
I don't support sanctions never voted to
sanction a sovereign country in the 11
years that I've been in Congress I think
it leads to war sanctions actually
create crimes only for US citizens
because we're not going to go put
somebody in jail in In Another Country
who trades with Iran what we're
proposing to do when we pass a sanction
is to make a federal law that would
result in the imprisonment of a US
citizen who who trades with Iran and it
hurts the people who are in the country
I think it actually edges us closer to
war instead of getting us out of War so
that and there were even more reasons to
vote against that um even even though I
support Israel and I condemned Hamas I
did that on my own I may I put out a
statement I support Israel's right to
defend itself and I condemn these
attacks but that wasn't enough one one
that you took even more heat for was
this one where you you were the only
vote against it and it was what I guess
you would describe as a virtue signal
Bill where um the essentially it's the
house reaffirming the state of Israel's
right to exist and two recognizing uh
that denying Israel's right to exist is
a form of
anti-Semitism um where are you coming
from on these sorts of bills that aren't
even really directly tied to any sort of
military aid or anything like that well
I I recognize Israel's right to exist
okay yeah uh I have to preface all of
this stuff with that because people
would imply from a vote that I don't but
um when they passed that I said you're
basically saying that that anti-zionism
is
anti-Semitism and people argued with me
that that wasn't Zionism you
know that that those words weren't a
proxy for Zionism well what's
interesting is the next week they passed
almost the same resolution and they
replaced Israel's right to exist with
Zionism so maybe I'm just giving them
clues for how to write their bills more
directly um because the next resolution
said that anti-zionism is anti-Semitism
and there are hundreds of thousands of
Jewish people who disagree with that
statement in fact Gerald Nadler who's
the most senior member of Congress who's
Jewish went to the floor and gave a five
minute
speech um which is a long speech in the
House of Representatives this isn't the
Senate but he gave a five minute speech
on why that's untrue to say that
anti-zionism is anti-Semitism now there
are a lot of people who are anti-Semitic
who are also U against the state of
Israel but you can't equate the two and
I think these uh 19 votes after today
are sort of a it's a it's part of the
war effort for Israel to make it hard
for the for anybody in the United States
to criticize what they're doing like you
every two or three days here in Congress
you have we're taking these votes that a
lot of what's in the resolution is just
obvious and doesn't need to be stated
it's kind of like black lives matter
okay you have to say black lives matter
now they're making they're doing the
equivalent with Israel now Israel
matters and so I agree that Israel
matters but we don't have to take all
these votes and and some of them are
going into campuses and trying to limit
free speech um by withholding Federal
money if you uh if if you allow anti
things that are considered anti-semitic
by the way let's take a a second just to
talk about that
word I've been called anti-semitic for
merely not supporting the money that
goes to Israel APAC ran an ad uh they
spent $90,000 in my district running
ads um implying that I was anti-semitic
and then in a tweet said that I was
anti-Semitic
for not spending not voting for The 14.3
billion to go to Israel even though I've
not voted for 4 and a to go to anywhere
ever do people do people buy that
talking point of
Apex um the ad was not effective like
when you when they run an ad in my
district that said Thomas Massie was the
Lone Republican to vote against this
resolution and um people are like back
in my district they've I have a history
of being the only vote like that was a
no vote like on the cares act and
explaining why it's a bad vote and then
a couple years later they you know they
find out wow why weren't why didn't
everybody vote the way he did so I've
developed some trust with my
constituents on those loan votes I mean
Chuck Chuck Schumer has accused you of
being anti-semitic on he's blasted you
on Twitter I me here's the Tweet he said
rep uh representative Massie you're a
sitting member of Congress uh this is
anti-Semitic disgusting dangerous and
exactly the type of thing I was talking
about in my Senate address take this
down and what he's referring to is the
uh Drake meme where he's uh saying uh
you know no no to American patriotism
yes to uh Zionism con Congress these
days um I mean were
you what was your reaction to having you
know the well someone as prominent as
Chuck Schumer uh accusing you of
anti-Semitism well we ratio him on that
pretty soundly um I quote tweeted him
and said if only you cared about half as
much about our border as you care about
my tweets and um he he's got like over
10,000 comments now on on his tweet to
me um it's I mean it's just simply not
true by the way in the replies to him
you'll find somebody who pointed out
that of of all 535 members of Congress
he rece this cycle he received more
money from pro-israel Lobby according to
open secrets.org than any other member
of Congress so um it just it rings
Hollow when he says that and even he's
even in disagreement with Gerald Nadler
for instance on equating anti-zionism to
anti-Semitism and I'll admit memes are
not the the most precise way to convey
um a a point but they can be effective
and there you know that Meme it doesn't
imply that there there's nothing in that
Meme that implies those two things are
mutually exclusive and that wasn't my
intent I was just pointing out that you
could you could it's okay in Congress to
be patriotic for Israel but you can't be
patriotic for America that's considered
nationalism which is American
nationalism is a dirty word and I know
it's loaded and there are a lot of
people that have attached themselves to
it but if you take it in the generic
sense it's you know pride in your
country so I Ed the word patriotism
pride pride in America is is looked down
upon right now it's out of fashion but
pride in Israel is something we have to
vote on two or three times a week now in
Congress it's almost like era where
political memes have sort of replaced um
old form of you know political satire
like we used to have staff cartoonists
at every single major print publication
in the United States and now it's kind
of interesting because this form has
been sort of democratized like anybody
can create a drake hotline bling meme uh
including sitting members of Congress
but I do think there's something
interesting about like you know memes
are obviously not the weightiest
possible form of conducting this
discourse with Chuck Schumer but they
are sort of how we do things nowadays I
think there's like something to be to be
mold on reflected on there about like
what that says about our political
culture I think it's maybe a good thing
yeah and listen I think most congressmen
if they got any controversy would throw
their staff under the bus and say the
staff created that Meme um the reality
is I like just did put meme generator in
a search engine found the you know the
blank meme I wanted and put those words
in there and my staff you you made the
meme I made the meme I didn't I didn't
tax that Meme I didn't steal it I
created it myself and my staff in fact
tried to talk me out of it
because they value their jobs they value
their jobs more than I value mine I
think but this is the re we needed yes
exactly and you mentioned you know
you've you've you have this reputation
now in your own district and nationally
as the guy who's willing to make the
meme or you know do make take the
unpopular vote um and I think the one of
the Prime examples of that is back in
the the depths of covid March
2020 everyone was pushing for this $2.2
trillion doll covid relief bill
including the president of the United
States and it was representative Thomas
Massie who was saying if we're going to
have a$2 million2 trillion dollar vote
here let's follow the Constitution and
have everyone come back to DC and
actually do it in person and for that
going back to Twitter the uh or you know
now X the kind of locust of political
discourse president Trump's response to
that was look like looks like a third
rate grandstander named representative
Thomas Massie a congressman from
unfortunately a truly great state
Kentucky wants to vote against the new
Save Our Workers Bill in Congress he
just wants the publicity he can't stop
it uh he goes on to say that uh you know
the Republicans should win the house but
they should kick out uh Thomas Massie I
mean what was that like having the eye
of Sauron on you for insisting on an
in-person vote in March
2020 oh well I'll have to write a book
someday but that those tweets happened
about 60 seconds after a phone call
ended between me and president Trump
where um he basically burned my ear off
screaming at me for probably three
minutes and said he was coming at me he
was going to take me down and um that's
a sobering proposition when you're
you've got a primary election eight
weeks away you've been trying to keep
the president out of your race the
person running against you says you
don't support the president enough and
the president had 95% approval rating
among the primary voters who were going
to vote in my election but um I just
stood strong I said listen if if
truckers and nurses and grocery store
workers are showing up for work then
Congress should show up for work too and
that was I think an unsalable
message because ultimately I was just
trying to get people on record the
reason I was trying to get people on
record is I knew this was one of the
worst votes in history and nobody was
going to be accountable for it um and so
I'm you know here we are three years
later every bad thing that I said would
happen as a result of of doing that has
happened and even my colleagues here in
Congress a lot of them admit to me um
that they were wrong about that they
won't say it too loudly lest anybody
hear it and I got 81% in that primary
you know with Trump screaming at me and
and tweeting at me and whatnot by the
way the the reporters came up to me as I
walked out of the chamber that day and
said your own president just called you
a third rate grandstander what do you
have to say and I said I was deeply
insulted I'm at least second rate um and
they didn't have a come back to that but
be
careful if you ask the um the
X uh chatbot or whatever you know the AI
that Elon Musk has on X if you ask it to
roast me it will say that I you know
like a washed up high school quarterback
I like to talk about that one event back
on March 27th 2020 too much and you know
it's kind of funny that it roasts me for
bringing that up so you if x is
listening if grock is listening I wanted
to know that you Zach brought it up not
me yes how much covid policy remorse is
there among your colleagues in congress
not enough not nearly enough um there
should be the policy isn't just the
spending the vaccine mandates the the
shutting down of our
economy uh the the pulsory masking the
way people were treated like cattle
there should be far more
remorse U but frankly that's a
reflection of the voters as well if you
poll this most people have moved on even
a year ago most people have moved had
moved on and it wasn't in the top five
issues of what people care about in any
congressional district you can't
campaign on well I tried to save you
during covid I mean look at um Ron de
santis that was part of his signature
issue and by being the you know
different Governors responded
differently but he most famously opposed
A lot of this covid nonsense after it
became obvious what we were dealing with
and um he rode that wave and he was
polling better than Trump but I think
people have moved on and they've got
other issues to think about now and um
that's you know people have just moved
on and so have my colleagues and I think
it's really unfortunate and I wished
that I had been able to get that
recorded vote that day we'd have a lot
more people who wouldn't be back here in
Congress perpetrating bad ideas like
fisa so I have one last question um and
then we'll wrap up because I know you
have other stuff to get to uh you're a
busy man but on that topic you know one
of the things that the cares act and
that the pandemic stimulus spending led
to um you know at least as far as I can
tell is inflation right like that's
something that's on American voters
Minds do you see any signs and also you
were elected during sort of the era of
the tea party you know reigning in
government spending a sense of well we
care about our fiscal health and so as a
result we can't just have the money
printer constantly print money forever
more we have to be prudent uh because
the bill always comes du do you think
that that message has any hopes of
having any sort of Revival in the coming
years especially given the runaway
inflation that we've seen or do you
think it's just a totally lost cause and
we're all
screwed let me assign a 95% probability
to that last proposition but I but I'm
I'm here in the 5 percent chance that
that we can save it and in the 30%
chance that if it all goes to hell in a
hand basket I can still be here and have
some credibility and putting it back
together um I think what's starting to
curb the appetite for spending and bring
some realism into the discussion is is
the only thing that was ever going to
curb our appetite for spending and that
is our creditors are starting to balk um
the the rates at which the government
can borrow money now aren't what we want
them to be when we go out to do an
auction or a sale for Treasury
or or bonds what we're finding is the
appetite isn't there even at 4 and a
half% you know to get guaranteed 4 and a
half% return on your money you know from
the government back by the US military
that's not enough to to loan that money
to the government they want 5% that's an
indicator that you know when the private
sector and and the other countries Who
The Sovereign you know funds who usually
uh have the appetite for our debt when
they're losing their appetite that's a
sign that things are going south and um
not not to promote it too much because
grock roasts me for this too but I wear
this debt clock that I built um in in
Congress to remind people of it and one
side effect of me wearing this is I've
noted I've noticed that because it by
the way it logs on to treasury's website
once a day gets the debt to the penny it
would do it more frequently but they
only publish it once a day as a
consequence of wearing this and looking
at it every day one thing I've noticed
is the rate at which the debt is
increasing is going
up so that like the for the math nerds
that's the second derivative and today
the debt per second is set averaged over
the last year
$78,000 a
second it's just I don't don't think
people realize it feels like we're going
over Niagara Falls right now to me the
rate at these bad things happening is is
increasing now oh good we got a graph I
love to see yeah this is just the debt
to GDP Rao in uh historical terms so you
can see that you know it exceeded the
high point of World War II uh and we're
you know at after World War II they
actually cut spending so I I don't how
this turns around at this point um but
with that that de clock pin though is
did like is that something you made like
where did you get you made that can Zach
and I buy them well I'm not gonna Liz I
refuse to monetize the debt um but but
um yeah that's a dad joke that only I
can say in these circumstances but um
there is a company I gave them the IP
and they are I don't want to advertise
it here because I'm in my office but um
if you look for it you can find a place
to get this I gave the code away and
they're making these and bringing shame
everywhere to I am I am giving them away
to other members of Congress as kind of
Badges of
Shame um we all need to be wearing this
and looking at it the best thing for me
though is when I'm in an elevator with
let's say some people who vot who always
vote for every spending Bill I just I
reach down and I I turn up the
brightness have three levels of
brightness and I've had that is the most
passive aggressive possible thing you
could do but it's for such a good cause
so I can't even be mad I had some people
ask me if that's the number of steps
I've taken and I'm like if I could run
at the speed of light I can't take I
wouldn't take this many steps this week
um and then somebody asked me if it was
the uh the Doomsday Clock like you know
one of the liberal Democrats and I'm
like well yeah it kind of is
and my wife uh told me maybe I shouldn't
wear this you know around the security
guards and stuff they would think it's a
bomb you know and I said well it is a
bomb I'm gonna wear it and let everybody
know the only thing is it doesn't count
down it counts up and we don't know
where the trigger is and when the bomb
goes
off fair enough uh on that note thank
you so much for talking to reason uh
next time you see us we will absolutely
be wearing these pins uh so me all
around New York City wearing this
awesome pin thank you so much we really
appreciate your time thanks Liz thanks
Zach thank
you thanks for listening to just asking
questions these conversations appear on
reason's YouTube channel and Facebook
page every Thursday and the just asking
questions podcast feed every Friday
subscribe wherever you get your podcast
and please rate and review the
show